john ballots are still being counted
this morning and that could continue for
several more days
hector mehim is live outside election
headquarters with details on the process
good morning hector
good morning officials here say the goal
is not to count fast but to count
accurately but it is taking longer than
it has in other states and there's a lot
of scrutiny here
and here's how important this is not
only do we have the nation watching here
but we also have journalists from around
the world standing outside our local
election department so it sort of feels
like we are
literally standing in the trenches of
history this morning
so what's actually left to count there
are about 190
thousand ballots that need to be
tabulated that's according to the nevada
secretary of state's office
90 percent of those votes are here in
clark county and at nine this morning
the state will update vote totals giving
us a clear picture
in terms of the accounting process
election workers are not running on the
24-hour shifts
we've seen in other states they're
sorting mail ballots from roughly
5 a.m up until 11 p.m every day until
they finish and the county could go to
into the weekend according to the
registrar of voters
they're dealing with security concerns
here as they count ballots
we have security here we have law
enforcement who are protecting us i am
concerned for the safety of my staff
we're putting measures into place to
make sure that we have the security
that's necessary
last night we saw a protest with
president trump supporters gathering
outside election headquarters
unhappy with how the results were going
so far and we're told counting mail
ballots is taking
a little longer because nevada has never
had this many mail ballots to deal with
and if you're
closely watching the results like the
whole country is here's the rundown
again
at 9 this morning the state will release
new numbers and then at 10 this morning
the county will give an update on their
progress and how long it could take for
us to get the final results here
in nevada reporting live in north las
vegas hector mejia
8 news now